I'm Dr. Skog, and this is your
OMM lecture on trigger points.
Here are your objectives for
this lecture. We're going
to talk about the criteria
for diagnosing trigger
points, review a specific
trigger point and its referral
pattern so we can
understand the link between
those things, talk about the
difference between trigger
points and other things
you have heard of, counter
strain points, fibromyalgia
tender points, and we'll
also discuss the treatment
process that you as
osteopathic physicians can use
to treat trigger points with
a little bit of comparison
to other medical
professionals and how they
might treat trigger points a
little bit differently and
finally talk about how to
keep trigger points from
coming back so what are trigger
points so this definition
is from travel and simon's
book it's the primary
source for trigger points
and their various referral
patterns and it's listed in
the references at the end
of this slideshow but their
definition is a hyper
irritable spot within a top
band of skeletal muscle and
thus this tender spot is
painful on compression
or stretch or overload or
contraction of that muscle
tissue and then leads to a
referred pain in another
area of the body that is not
exactly the muscle that has
the trigger point in it.
So our key elements for
diagnosis of a trigger point
are a tender point, a top
band of muscle where the
tender point is located, and
a referred pain pattern. You
have to have those elements
to have a trigger point.
You can actually see this
top band of muscle on
ultrasound, but ultrasound is
not necessary to diagnose a
trigger point sometimes
ultrasound is used for treating
trigger points if the
point in particular is near
like a delicate neurovascular
structure that you want
to make sure that you are
avoiding with your treatment
of the trigger point trigger
points are a specific
type of somatic dysfunction
and they are a component
of myofascial pain syndrome
which is a term that we
will come back to a little
bit later in this lecture
So this image is actually
a muscle biopsy of a piece
of muscle tissue with a
trigger point in it. So if
we start at the bottom
where the orange arrow is
pointing to, you can see there
is a band of normal muscle
there with regularly spaced
sarcomeres. And remember,
each sarcomere is going
to be one dark band with
kind of half of the light
color band on either side
of it, Maybe one sarcomere.
And then you can compare
to the actual contractured,
not circled in blue
above, which is the trigger
point. There are also
sarcomeres in that area, but
it's so compressed that you
can barely even tell there
are lines there. And then
on either side, highlighted
by these green arrows,
is the elongated circle
mirrors on either side
of that trigger point,
compensating for that
super compressed area
in the middle. The next
slide is this exact same
picture, but the arrows
and the circles taken off
of it, so now that you
know what you're looking
for, that you can
actually see the image a
little bit better. This
image emphasizes the point
that we usually find several
contracture knots present
in one trigger point. So
if you look at this picture
here of this longitudinal
section of muscle, it's got
the top band label, it's
got the nodule labeled,
which is the trigger point,
and then that part is
pulled out in section B of
this image, and you can see
that this is one trigger
point, but that one
trigger point has several
different little contracture
knots within it. And so
we'll come back to this
when we talk about treatment
and moving your needle
around if you treat your
trigger points with needling
to break up all of those
contracture knots within
just one trigger point.
Here's an illustration
of another typical
characteristic of trigger
points so on thermal imaging
which is what we see here
the actual trigger point
is a little hotter than
the surrounding area due
to the muscle contraction
actually producing heat
but the trigger point is
surrounded by a significantly
cooler area this is because
fascia is restricted
around that point and
it decreases blood flow
to the trigger point or
to that contracture knot.
You can actually feel
this cooler area on
exam when you are
examining a patient's
muscle for trigger
points. On the above image
of trigger points
in the lumbar spine,
on the left here, the purple
is slightly warmer than
the surrounding black, which
is the coldest color on
this scale that they have
here, and you can see the
distinct shape of two trigger
points which are circled
and labeled c1 and c2
before treatment of trigger
points and then on the right
the same area with this
line here in l1 lumbar
segment one is labeled after
treatment five days after
treatment is significantly
warmer after the trigger
points have been treated
so remember that your true
criteria for diagnosis are
your tender point it's in a
top band of muscle, and it
produces a referred pain
pattern in a specific area.
The last slide and this
slide are not criteria
for diagnosis, but
they are confirmatory
criteria, basically meaning
that if you find these
things, it helps you to know
that you are in the right
place to be treating the
pain that the patient came to
see you for or the symptoms
that the patient can see
you for. So if you're going
along and you think, oh,
based on this referral pattern,
I think that this trigger
point is in this muscle
and you're feeling it and
you feel that cool area, you
can say to yourself, okay,
this is a confirmatory sign
that I think I'm in the
right place. The same thing
for the two items listed on
this slide, the jump sign.
And this is a patient pain
response, basically when
seeing withdrawal response,
when you get to the trigger
point that's causing the
problem and the local
twitch response which is a
transient contraction of that
top band of skeletal muscle
where the trigger point is
located when you press on
it and also often actually
produces the referred pain.
And this is an image of
a trigger point seen on
ultrasound which is the
most typical modality that
we use for imaging trigger
points if we need to.
So if you're not used to
looking at ultrasounds,
sometimes it can look
a little bit like, you
know, here's some gray and
here's some other gray.
So let's take a second to
orient ourselves. So this
is labeled here as the
abdominal ****** muscle. The
muscle is this horizontal
band across the middle
so it's dark in the middle
and it's got this almost
highlighted edges to the
muscle and that again that's
that horizontal band going
basically all the way
through the middle of the
image here and then right
in the middle of that
muscle we see this lighter
gray area identified by
an arrow on the top and an
arrow on the bottom which is
the trigger point we would
say that since it's
lighter gray that is more
echogenic on ultrasound and
that is because the cervical
mirrors are more contracted
in that lighter gray
area that is identified
as the trigger point here.
So we know that to have
a trigger point you have
to have a tender point
that is within a top band
of muscle and so this image
is what that looks like.
Over on the left, the
fingers are kind of coming
toward you. That's what
that angle is. And then
you can see in the pink
part at the bottom, there
is a trigger point with
a red dot in the middle.
The trigger point is felt as
a small nodular or spindle
shaped thickening within
that top band of skeletal
muscle tissue. And then you
can see in BNC on the right
that that knot is
being stabilized
between the physician's
two fingers in
order to hold it in
place for treatment.
In large flat muscles like
the quadratus lumborum,
the fingertips can be
drawn along the muscle
perpendicular to its
fibers as in the previous
slide, the large flat
muscle like that, but some
muscles like the trapezius
or those in the axillary
folds are better palpated
with a pincer grip,
again, to get hold of
that trigger point in a
way that is perpendicular
to the muscle fibers.
so here's an example of a
referral pattern for the
supraspinatus muscle and
so you can see over on the
left side of the image the
actual representation of
the supraspinatus muscle
and over on the right side
of the image you can see
the front and back of a
person with the dark red
area indicating the usual
referral pain pattern, which
you can see is not where
the muscle actually is.
And then the red dots are
the sort of rollover areas
where your patients might
say, but when it's really
bad, then it goes into
these other areas or you
might find the referral of
that trigger point to be
more rarely in those areas.
So this image and example is
from the Travell book that
we will keep referencing
from this lecture. The latest
version has all of these
sort of little titles, I
guess, to help you remember
the different muscles, and
it has labeled supraspinatus
as the overhead activity
archenemy. So you can look
at those if you'd like to.
This commonly, you find
a trigger point in the
supraspinatus for
people who work or do
recreational activities
that require elevating
the arm over the head.
So I can overuse injury
recreational sports
such as basketball or
volleyball that have
some of that repetitive
overhead elevation
using this muscle.
Patients with a supraspinatus
trigger point will
often describe intense
pain in that lateral aspect
of the shoulder over the
deltoid, which you can see
marked in dark red on the
right hand images here.
It may go down as
far as the lateral
epicondyle and even down
the forearm further.
People usually describe
feeling this pain
when they elevate the
arm at the glenohumeral
joint, especially
when they start
that overhead movement
or that abduction.
it may be mistaken for bursitis
initially in the shoulder joint
these people with a trigger
point in the supraspinatus
muscle will often report
difficulty in things
like reaching overhead
to comb or brush their
hair to brush their teeth
or to shave for some
patients or during sports
activities that they like
to do that require arm
elevation, like serving
in tennis. All of this
should sound really familiar
to you as things that we
ask about for potential
rotator cuff symptoms
or rotator cuff injury.
And patients may actually
come to you having already
had some kind of workup,
possibly even an mri for a
rotator cuff tear but there's
no tear there right so
they're looking for some other
reason why they're having
these rotator cuff symptoms
another point to this is
that a lot of times you won't
just find trigger points
in one muscle you will find
trigger points in sort of
a group of muscles that work
together so you may find
trigger points not just in
the supraspinatus muscle,
but also in some of those
other rotator cuff muscles.
Okay, so now we're going to
add just a little bit more
nuance to our definition of
trigger points in that the
referral pattern doesn't
only include pain at the
referral site, which brings
us then to the definition of
myofascial pain syndrome.
So we talked about on the
previous slide that use of
the supraspinatus muscle or
even pressing on a supraspinatus
tender point will often
produce pain within that
referral pattern in the
image on that last slide,
but it can also produce motor
symptoms, weakness or stiffness.
Sometimes people might
say, I don't know how to
describe it to you, but it's
almost like my arm feels
heavy when I try to use it.
You can also have autonomic
symptoms within that
referral pattern, so
blanching, or that arm
might be colder than
the other arm, you know,
to your own exam, or the
patient might feel that
it's colder as well.
You might have other
autonomic symptoms such
as sweating or goosebumps.
So then the myofascial
pain syndrome definition
is the sensory, motor,
and autonomic symptoms
caused by myofascial
trigger points in a
specific muscle or in a
specific muscle group.
Trigger points are
caused by muscle
overload leading to
biomechanical stress.
And so muscles can
be overloaded by
mechanical stress,
postural, for example,
your forward head carriage,
and we'll talk a little
bit more about this at the
very end of the lecture.
Structural, such as a
pelvic shear that you've had
for a long time or nominate
shear. static, such
as an acute muscle strain,
or dynamic, such as a
repetitive motion injury
or overload of the muscle.
Various types of
jobs can be prone to
repetitive motion
injuries like this.
Predisposing factors to
mechanical stress can
include genetic factors,
such as Ehlers-Danlos
syndrome, which is a
hypermobility disorder.
Nutritional
deficiencies of various
sorts, calcium for
sure, potassium,
magnesium.
Metabolic imbalance
such as hypothyroidism
can make you more
prone to muscle
overload and then
developing trigger points.
Other trigger points are a risk
factor for muscle
overload as well.
A functional myotatic unit
is really a group of muscles
that share the same functional
responsibilities, such
as the muscles that work
together to abduct the arm.
And so functional overuse
may result in associated
trigger points within
a given myotatic unit.
Satellite trigger points,
on the other hand, may
develop in muscles
that are covered by the
referred pain pattern of
another myofascial trigger
point. So, in our example
of the supraspinatus,
you might find a satellite
trigger point if, for example,
in the deltoid or the biceps
or something like that
in the referral pain pattern
of the supraspinatus.
so there are a bunch of
different theories um about
the pathophysiology of trigger
points but no one consensus
so i'd really like to
just talk about this image
at a very high level and i
only need you to know just
the general idea of what's
going on so we have direct
stimuli such as you know
muscle fatigue or muscle
overload trauma to a muscle
or postural strain going
to a spinal segment or set
of segments. Then we have
the indirect stimuli such
as from various organs that
are associated with certain
spinal segments and we
have here in our example
like T1 to 4 is the one with
the area of facilitation.
So all of this persistent
stimuli makes this particular
area of the spinal segment
facilitated. Facilitated
in this context just means
almost like super sensitive
or really easily triggered.
So it seems like at that
point, when you have
this area already facilitated,
then any little thing
makes it output then to the
pain reference zone, and
that's how you get your
pain referral pattern. And
that is all I need you to
know about that for now.
Most of what we've been
talking about so far would be
considered active trigger
points. So the main difference
between an active trigger
point and a latent trigger
point is that palpating an
active trigger point will
usually trigger the patient's
usual referred pain or
other referred symptoms, but
palpating a latent trigger
point will produce pain that
is not the patient's usual
symptom or usual pain that
they have. Latent trigger
points sometimes may not
be associated as much with
pain as they are with more
reduced range of motion or
perceived stiffness or
perceived weakness in that area.
Active trigger points have
pain when patients use that
muscle. That's what that
means by spontaneous pain.
Whereas latent trigger
points are really
only painful when
they are palpated or
treated. That's what
needled is here.
Both active and latent
trigger points are
actually common. Active
can be much easier to
diagnose for beginners,
but latent trigger
points are also very
important not to miss.
How are trigger
points different from
counterstrain points or
fibromyalgia tender points,
which they are often
compared to both of these
things. So we'll talk
about this briefly.
Counterstrain points are
really on the same continuum
as trigger points. They're
essentially untreated or
hypersensitive for whatever
reason. Counterstrain points
turn into trigger points.
Remember that counterstrain
points, though, do not
cause referred pain. So if
you feel a point in the
muscle and you're like, wow, I
wonder if this is a
counterstrain point or trigger
point, if you press on it and
they have pain in the typical
referral pattern for
that muscle, it is not a
counterstrain point and
likely won't respond just to
counterstrain. will have to
be treated as a trigger point.
Fibromyalgia tender points
actually are counter
strain points that are
just very common in
patients who have a
diagnosis of fibromyalgia.
Fibromyalgia, in addition,
often includes a total body
increase in pain sensitivity.
And then, as I just said,
those classic sort of
symmetrical counter strain
points in these classic areas
those tender points used
to be part of the diagnosis
criteria for fibromyalgia but
they are not anymore they've
included on the next slide
just an image of where
those classic fibromyalgia
tender points are treatment
of trigger points is
also referred to as
inactivation of trigger
points you can treat them
with omm muscle energy
counter strain soft tissue,
HVLA, myofascial
release, neuromuscular
inhibition are all used
to treat trigger points.
Spray and stretch is
another technique that can
be used and is also
under the manual therapy
sort of title. You can
also treat them with
needling. A lot of you
may have heard of dry
needling. This is
something that physical
therapists actually do
quite a bit where they will
put a needle into a trigger
point in a specific muscle
and just kind of move it
around basically breaking
up all of those little
contracture knots that are
in that one trigger point
that sometimes this is
called peppering where they
just sort of gently move
that needle up and down.
That's what that is called.
Wet needling is something
that is available to you as
osteopathic physicians is
basically the same thing as
dry needling except you
use a hypodermic needle so
you can inject a little
bit of lidocaine into that
trigger point. Both of these
are effective treatments, but
patients report a little bit
less soreness immediately
after the treatment with
the lidocaine injection.
And lidocaine is, of
course, an anesthetic.
But other health professionals
will do dry needling
if it is not within
their scope of practice
to do injections. So
that's why sometimes that
one is chosen over using
a lidocaine injection.
So this is an image of
spray and stretch. It's
just what it sounds like.
A vapo coolant spray is
applied in this image to
the upper trapezius here.
Note that it is applied
over both the muscle
causing the problem and
its referral pattern area.
The cooling spray
really is just like a
like a topical anesthetic.
You may have seen
this actually on some of
your pre-med shadowing
experiences. If you shadow
like in an orthopedics
office, a lot of times
they'll spray with a
cooling spray before
they do a joint injection
or sometimes in pediatrics
or family medicine
offices they'll use
before various injections.
Notice in this case on the
spray side of this image
like even up into this
person's hair they spray
it all so and then once
there is a little bit of
that cooling spray applied
then they will stretch out
that muscle and that's
what the second image is.
And this is an image of a
trigger point being treated
with either wet needling or
dry needling so again the
physician will sort of trap
that trigger point between
their two fingers with a
little bit of pressure, and
then place the needle into
the trigger point. And the
reason you use your fingers
to sort of trap that
trigger point is it will tend
to try to avoid the needle
and sort of roll out of the
way if you don't do that.
And then once you have
inserted the needle into the
trigger point, then you just
do that peppering motion
just a little bit of up
and down without completely
withdrawing the needle and
break up any little contracture
knots that you find within
that one trigger point.
So this is a little
bit of a busy slide,
but it has all of
the steps. So you
want your patient
to be lying down.
Sometimes people start to
feel a little bit faint
when they see or feel
needles. so just have
them lying down in the
first place. You clean the
site with an alcohol
swab, you put on your cold
spray, and you can pull
the skin to trap the
trigger point. You insert
the needle. The trigger
point kind of feels like
a little rubber ball.
Sometimes you'll get that
local twitch response
when you insert the
needle into the trigger
point, and that is one
thing that lets you
know that you are in
exactly the right place.
You are going to break up
multiple loci, so all of
those little contracture
knots that you can find
within one trigger point.
Then you'll withdraw the
needle, you'll apply pressure
to the area, and then,
this is super important
for getting a good result
to your trigger point
treatment, is then once you
have broken up all of
those little contracture
knots, then you have to
stretch the muscle. So you
could do like muscle
energy technique, you could
have the patient actively
do a particular stretch
after you have had the wet
needling or dry needling.
Then you want to assess
your post-treatment
pain. A lot of times
the patients will
immediately notice some
relief of their symptoms.
And this is the other
very important point that
sometimes gets forgotten, is
that you need to work with
them to figure out how to
keep their trigger points
from coming back. And
we'll talk about this in a
little more detail in the
rest of the slides, but a lot
of times the way people
sleep, as we said, their
postures for their
recreational activities or the
things that they do at work
will need to be addressed.
They will need to do some
self-stretching at home,
exercise prescriptions
for stretching and
strengthening the
involved muscles and their
antagonists. And these
are going to be different
for every trigger point
in every muscle or
muscle group. And this
is where you would go
back again to the
Trevelle book and look at,
in our example, the section
on the supraspirnatus
muscle, and we'll give
you some examples of
what stretches should
this patient be doing,
what activities should
they avoid, what should
their exercise prescription
be. So it is a very
practical book for you
to use in the clinic.
if you don't have all
the trigger points
memorized, which
most people do not.
This is an example of a
patient using a trigger
point pressure release
tool. So this is
something that a patient
could have at home and
they could use on their
own trigger point in
the area of the supraspinatus
in this example.
And it can help
them to inactivate
the trigger point on their own.
the reason that it is
you know in this sort of
funny shape is because it
allows them to get pressure
on the point while keeping
the arm on the same
side that that the point
is on relaxed because
that will help to inactivate
the point if you're not
also sort of tensing that
arm on the same side.
Remember your patients
will need to do a cell
stretch regimen at home and
so image A here on the left
is an example of a self
-stretch of the supraspinatus
muscle. And image B is
an alternative stretch
that the patient can do
at home if they can't get
into the position that's
in image A there on the
left, which some people
can't, at least at first.
So let's put some things
together. This slide looks
similar to that high-level
pathophysiology slide we
discussed earlier but this
time instead of only a
myofascial input to the
spinal cord we also have input
to the same levels from
other stimuli so on the top
left we have the heart and
it has some narrowing here
um vessel narrowing causing
symptoms of angina which
if you haven't had that
yet is just chest pain
usually with exertion like
chest pain with walking out
to your mailbox and the
sympathetic nervous system
levels associated with
cardiac function are T1 to T5.
Because these levels, T1 to
T5, are already facilitated
by the cardiac input, it
takes less stimulus to
overload the overlying
pectoralis major muscle on the
left, which is shown at the
top right of this drawing.
So somatic dysfunction from
this muscle also inputs
to these spinal levels,
T1 to T5. If the stimulus
goes on for long enough,
then they develop trigger
points in the pectoralis
major on that left side.
Now suddenly you have
left-sided chest pain
radiating down the
left arm. No, oh no!
Even if you haven't had
cardiac yet, that should
be a little bit of a red
flag for you. So they go
to the emergency room, they
get an EKG, they get the
appropriate workup, but
it's not a heart attack.
So this person may be put
on medication to treat
their angina, which
does help with the chest
pain. And they say, that's
really great, doctor,
but I still have this
pain in my left arm. So we
can treat out the remaining
somatic dysfunction
as well as the dysfunction
at the T1 to T5
spinal levels. See that
in the bottom left corner.
You're likely to find
your TART changes there,
likely a type 1
or type 2 somatic
dysfunction within that area.
Don't worry about Chapman's
points if you haven't
learned about those yet, but
the one associated with the
heart is on the left in that
second intercostal space.
So if we just treated
out the trigger points in
that pec major muscle,
they would come back after
a while. We also have
to treat the angina with
appropriate medication and
lifestyle modifications.
And on the other side,
if we only treated
the anginous symptoms,
it wouldn't necessarily
treat the somatic
dysfunction in the pec
major or at T1 to T5
in the thoracic spine.
So this is taking a holistic
approach incorporating
several of the osteopathic
models. So we have
the respiratory circulatory
model, including the
cardiac input, the
biomechanical model with the
somatic dysfunction
of the left pectoralis
muscle, the neurological with
the sympathetic activation
at those thoracic levels
that are associated
with these visceral and
muscular dysfunctions.
The behavioral model
comes into play with this
patient's continuing day
-to-day function. If you
don't treat both the angina
and the pectoralis trigger
point, this patient
is less likely to feel
comfortable starting to
exercise and be active, actually
stretching and using
that arm, which can lead
them then to further
cardiac risk in the future.
So all of these things
coming together in this one
slide here. On the next
slide, we'll talk a little
bit more about keeping
trigger points or somatic
dysfunction from coming back
after you've treated that.
So these are some examples
of patients who might
come in who are at risk of
postural deviations that
can lead to recurrence
of their trigger points.
This first list, the top
list, is mostly sort of
static strain, people who
stay in the same position
for a long time, like
truck drivers, construction
workers, administrative
assistants, may stay seated
for a lot of the time.
Dental hygienists sometimes
have to get into certain
postures and stay there for
a long time. And then
this second or bottom list
is more dynamic postural
concerns or repetitive strain
that leads to some muscles
being tight and then
other muscles being
weak. So weightlifting,
swimming, cycling,
running, gymnastics.
Each of these abnormal
postures shows some
muscles that are
chronically lengthened
and inhibited and
others, often their
antagonists, that are
shortened or facilitated.
And again,
facilitated just means
that the threshold
is lowered for the
intensity of that
muscle's response.
So the darker red
muscles in each
posture will be
triggered more easily.
Often what this means in
practical terms is that
the patient comes in
noticing a problem in one of
these lighter red areas,
in their core or in their
back, but you need to
correct the areas or muscle
groups highlighted in the
dark red, the chronically
contracted areas, in order
to really treat it, and
then keep the issue from
returning with stretches
that will improve the
problematic posture. And so
you have in a sort of
your lordotic posture with
increased lordosis in the
lumbar and cervical spines,
B, you know, your flat
back posture where
you've lost some of
that thoracic kyphosis,
and then C, you've
got your forward head
carriage sort of
kyphotic posture there.
So for example,
someone who has a, for
instance, chronically
anteriorly rotated pelvis
will likely have a
shortened or facilitated
psoas and iliacus
within lengthened or
inhibited abdominal
muscles or gluteus maximus.
Someone with hypertrophic
hamstrings like
a runner who may not
be cross training might
have then an inhibited
gluteus maximus.
So next year, next year
you will have a couple of
lectures on upper cross syndrome
and lower cross syndrome
by Dr. Koyman that will go
into a lot more detail about
this concept, and at that
point you will have to know
specific muscle groups
and their antagonists, but
you don't have to memorize
any of these muscles for this
lecture just to understand
the basic concept of tight
muscles and then their
antagonists often or counterparts
then becoming weakened or
chronically lengthened.
Finally, I leave you with
this image from the Travelle
book of this person,
who could be any of us,
engaging in poor posture
while looking at their phone,
and then their new and
improved posture for
phone browsing with four
folded over pillows.
Notice in the last
picture on the right that
they have much improved
posture from their head
carriage all the way
down through their spine.
um you may not seem like
the coolest cat in your
friend group to carry
around four pillows all
the time when you're hanging
out or you know waiting
for your appointment
at the doctor's office
or whatever but when you're
all 40 we'll just see
who's laughing and who
has persistent back pain